free agency hindsight would you rather
have and let's look at this right out of
the gates yeah the eagles signing joe
flacco to a one-year deal three and a
half million fully guaranteed he can
make another four million in incentives
shows how much he loves football this is
a guy who was the highest paid player in
football two different times still at it
still going taking what he can get would
you rather have him for one year and 3.5
or mitchell trubisky for one year and
2.5 chris this is a tight one because
joe vlacko is a really good backup to
have
i mean he is he's a guy that i think can
come off the bench
and not flinch and because he played and
done all those things but i'm i'm gonna
go with mitchell trubisky still i am you
know just because i think of the
athleticism that he can bring to the
table and do that you know it's a guy
that you know has played a lot of
football over the last few years you
know flacco's had injuries he's got the
neck issue and i know he got to play
last year but there hasn't been a lot of
play uh so i'm gonna give a slight edge
to mitchell trubisky more just because
of the athleticism and where the age and
where he's at in his career uh compared
to joe flacco but it's close black is a
good backup
well and it underscores the fact that
the eagles regard the backup quarterback
position as critical to the roster they
have to be ready to put a guy in at a
moment's notice and they saw what
happened in 2017 they won the super bowl
with a good backup different style than
jalen hurts and i don't know how willing
or eager flacco will be to mentor hertz
i remember when flacco was in denver and
they drafted drew locke he said my job
is not to mentor drew locke now flacco
is the example of the guy who arrives as
the starter via trade with the ravens
and then they draft drew lock and it's
like what the heck i thought i was the
guy he goes into this knowing he's not
the guy he goes into this knowing that
jalen hurts is the guy i i tell you what
for what they need by way of helping
someone with jail and hurts if flacco's
if flak goes all in with that then then
i think i'd rather have flacco yeah it's
a really it's a it's a tough one and i
you know i and
both have had a history of they can come
off the bench and be good i mean we saw
mitchell trubisky this year you know
do that you know uh we also saw nick
foles do that
behind him but yeah i'm with you with
flacco there is some other angles that
he brings especially in a jalen hurts
situation that are special where
trubisky is not going to bring a whole
lot to
you know josh allen and his development
it's just going to be about what he does
on the field if he gets a chance
all right would you rather sign dak
prescott to his record contract four
years 160 million which is a practical
matter it's three years 126 and then you
better get him signed to another record
contract or he's walking away in free
agency or just let him walk away now
with the market down with the cap down
and him coming off of a broken ankle
that every other team out there would
have been concerned about what would you
rather have done in hindsight
listen it's really interesting it is i
mean i do sit here and wonder and go
well what what did dak prescott got on
the open market especially when he's by
the time he signed his contract and did
those type of things
you know there's not a lot of positions
to be to be had out there as far as
starting quarterback but i still think
it's too risky you know i still think
there's there's teams out there and
listen there's just only so many times
when you get
the guy for your football team and you
know wait this guy is the guy that we
can win with you know and win
consistently
over the next eight to ten years that
that's rare so yes i do think they
overpaid him a little bit there's no
doubt but i still think i would rather
have him in his record contract than
have rolled the dice and let him test
the market and we'll see what happens
that would have been the ultimate boss
move by jerry jones all the credit he
got false credit yeah for having unique
information about the fact that new tv
deals were coming he's the only one who
knew that what a load of crap that was
everybody knew that the new tv deals
were coming if you want a crystal ball
your crystal ball is the market is
completely going to collapse guys are
going to be rushing to do one-year deals
or sign their franchise tags right maybe
we shouldn't have tagged him who maybe
we should have let him go
who was going to give him
42 million a year on a three-year deal
with 95 million of it fully guaranteed
sight unseen with a broken ankle no one
that's that's where like you know again
we didn't we didn't know we're just
seeing these questions here all right
but let's just go through this little
exercise real quick like who are the
teams out there that would legitimately
be interested i mean just right off the
top of my head i just said washington
washington right they're probably scared
to have done it i don't know but that
probably scared the hell out of the
cowboys a little bit to go wait
washington needs a quarterback and
they're kind of good like that could be
thrown right back into our face so maybe
that's the reason you know we know that
the patriots of course had the money and
the need at the time uh you know the
49ers i don't know if they would have
done it or not but we've heard enough
the the bears certainly right uh the
indianapolis colts maybe before the
carson wentz thing went down that's a
possibility so maybe they evaluated that
a little bit and said well some of these
teams have a real need and money and
that's where you got to pay it and i
think that's why i come back to
you know it's okay yeah you overpaid a
little bit but still you got your guy
i think the real risk for the cowboys
would have been that
even though they would have had the best
financial offer
prescott may have said
i'm leaving to make a point right and
and that's where you have to call his
bluff on he's always acted like it's no
big deal to be the cowboys quarterback
no big deal make a bunch of money off
the field no big deal set myself up for
a broadcasting career making 20 million
a year like romo no big deal
i don't think he would have left i don't
think he would have left yeah i i would
have loved to have seen the all-in move
from the cowboys especially because it's
not my money and it's not my team i
would have loved to have seen what would
have happened if they just said
we're not going to tag you this is our
offer and you can either take it or
leave it right but uh we need to know
what you're going to do and it ain't
going to be 42 million a year over three
years with most of it essentially
guaranteed all right ryan fitzpatrick to
a one-year 10 million dollar deal or
andy dalton do a one-year 10 million
dollar deal which would you rather have
had i would rather have ryan fitzpatrick
i would you know and again i listen i
know andy dalton went to the playoffs
and he's he's good and can do a lot of
things but that was a team that drafted
him and kind of formulated a a way
around him for their team to succeed you
know in this particular situation
i think like you know hey guys that are
coming in to be a one-year stopgap type
of guy fitzpatrick brings more to the
table in my opinion first off i think
he's just a better player at this point
he's more of an aggressive thrower
decision maker and here's the other
thing where i would favor ryan petra he
does bring an edge to your football team
you know there's an edginess to him
there is something about his passion the
way he plays the way he leads you see it
on the football field you know that that
to me would be one of my issues with
andy dalton i've never seen a let's go
guys what the hell are we doing i'm
pissed off you know i'm happy i mean i
never see that so i think fitzpatrick
brings more to your team from that
aspect too let alone i think he's a
little bit better of a player right now
my big concern with fitzpatrick is
there's always
something that goes off the rack
the rails and it's always spectacular uh
which is great for entertainment
purposes but yeah the fit's magic fits
tragic toggle switch
uh when when you're all in with him
it falls apart and then you expect
nothing from him and he amazes you and
it's good entertainment i just don't
know if it's the kind of good consistent
football you're looking for i frankly i
i
i think dalton is getting a raw deal he
took a team to the playoffs five
straight years to start his career and
you know if you're not a star and if
you're it's it's like the ultimate pass
fail you're either a star or you're crap
in the eyes of so many fans you can
still be pretty good and not be a star
no doubt um no doubt there's a certain
and i know there's a certain irony in
that comment given the things i've said
about kirk cousins over the years all
right uh
would you have rather franchise tagged
alan robinson at 17.98 million
test the market did i skip one all right
let me go back to one all right fine
that's all right well let's do this one
first since we're already there and then
we can circle back around would you have
rather
tagged alan robinson or let him hit the
market oh
i mean looking at it in hindsight i'd
rather him tested the market i think i i
just looking at it
i'm a little conflicted here and again
it's i'm trying to figure this out on
the fly as we go
you know
one there's the argument of like
you know we don't have a guy like this
and alan robinson is a legit number one
receiver he's a difference maker i mean
he's had a lot of good years with some
really crappy offenses and quarterback
play we know that you know and he is one
of those guys that even when he's
covered he's he's not covered you can
throw him the ball and it's not 50 50
it's 70 30. um
so i
i'm i'm really torn with this one but i
think like with where you see the market
at for the position
i don't know i'm going to change my mind
i'm going to say no you know what you
you tag them you don't let a guy that
the maybe the best player on your
offense out the door and have to bid
with somebody even though that maybe
they would have got them for less i
don't know you just don't let that
happen so i'm gonna go franchise tagging
him was the right thing to do
if their motivation was tag and trade
they shouldn't have done it because
they're going to have a hell of a time
trading him with 17. that's very true
he's given given the rest of the market
right um if you really want to keep him
if you really do want to keep him and
you really value him
i know i still top one yeah it's again i
we know the market now too i think
that's chain you know that's it's harder
to say it now or easier to say that now
than it was you know 10 days ago or two
weeks ago
and you always do run the risk that he's
going to leave just out of spite he's
going to say i'm not going to come back
there because you had your chance and
i'll take less somewhere else just
because you had your chance and i'm
going to stick it to you now that i have
the opportunity trent williams 60.8
million for three years or joe tooney 48
million for three years
and we're talking about the real years
of the contract yeah that's right you
hear the big numbers on the back and
it's the real money 60.8 for trent
williams 48 for joe tooney which would
you rather have i'm going to take trent
williams i am i you know you've heard me
gushing about i like joe tooney a lot i
really do i mean he's he's a really damn
good guard trenton williams to me is
generational left tackle that that
there's a difference there you you could
you know joe tooney
you know is is
real good in a lot of areas but i could
sit here with trent williams and go
no he's the best pass protecting left
tackle in football and i don't think a
lot of people are going to argue they go
well what about baccatiari and that and
but it's okay it's gonna be like him and
maybe a laramie tunzel in that
conversation and then i can go well no
he's the best run blocking left tackle
in football too and that to me is what
sets him apart from from others like
toonie you know you could say he's top
in one area but not towards the top of
another area trent williams just has no
flaws to his game he's special so i
would rather do that
my answer is very simple and this gets
back to the admonition that i have as it
relates to free agency generally
if a guy changes teams on the open
market there's a reason for that and
bill belichick was willing to let joe
tooney go just like he was willing to
let trent brown go a couple of years ago
trent williams stayed with his team yeah
that money's coming from a team that
knows him even though he wasn't with the
49ers for more than a year he was with
shanahan before that in washington
he knows what he's getting he values the
guy the chiefs
move was more of uh
we got to do something
we we got rid of eric fisher we got rid
of mitchell schwartz we got to do
something it can't be that meme of
patrick mahomes with no one else around
him and 11 defenders we got to do
something so i'd rather have trent
williams just because i'm going to defer
to the institutional knowledge that led
to williams staying put and toony
leaving yeah i i think you're you know
you're right there that's that's the way
i would look at it you know um there's
something there the patriots also were
in a very they're in a position where
they're all lines in a pretty damn good
spot too so i think they're happy with
that but
you know i don't think i could sit here
with joe tooney and go he's top two or
three at anything right you know he's
he's really good in all areas but i
don't i wouldn't say oh he's one of the
three best run blocking guards in
football or oh he's one of the three
best pass blocking he's had years where
he's been top three maybe in one of
those but like trent williams is a guy
like it's been every year of his career
you go
he's the best he is the best is the top
of the line in everything he does so
that's that's the difference to me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports